我跟大家讲，
我看那个电视剧是否里面明兰的那个婚姻态度，
就是我现实生活中的婚姻态度，
就两口子相处，
我不能指望他太多，
他只要完成了他的规定性的动作就已经很好了，
更多的事情还是得靠我自己，
因为我指望他干这个，
指望他干那个，
指望越多就难免会失望，
生活当中各有各的难处，
失望一多了之后就心生怨怼，
怨怼一多了之后就心生仇恨了，
那这日子就没法往下过了。
当老公冷战人了，
他打我，
打我之后，
现在我回老家了，
冷战了大概两三个月了，
他马上没回来，
没回来之后，
我自己先去河南旅游了一趟，
后面回来他态度还是很不好，
没办法，
我就叫我爸妈过来就来接我了，
我跟从假父母这边的哥说的这个事儿，
他就叫我自己的亲生父母过来接的，
待了一个月把小孩也带回来了，
接这江西了嘛，
大概十几天，
他也没联系我，
我孩子肯定要上学啥的，
我就跟他联系，
我说孩子要上学的话，
要不就过来，
后面他过来了，
他也没跟我说，
也没打电话跟我爸妈说从山西过来之后，
直接给我打电话，
说来了让我们家楼下，
我爸妈说那就别让他下来了，
因为没打招呼嘛，
就不太尊重我们，
我家人他妈就跟他见了个面，
见个面他态度也是不好，
他就说了，
我下来家西了哥。
不是说过来打我们，
就这种挑衅的话，
我也很生气，
大家就谈的不是特别好，
不过而上啊，
他说要跟小孩一起狂，
打电话说要四连见，
当时有点不舒服，
他就一到了家里头，
我父母可能也有点不高兴了，
说你为什么让他见小孩去见小孩，
我可能性格比较话，
我那个老公他就上去了，
就上去敲门了，
我爸妈一开门就把他给打了，
他就立马跑出父母让他见小孩子，
说我不太想跟他见面了，
找个理由就是车子坏了呀啥的，
他就很生气，
咱俩别说这些细节啊，
咱俩说具体现在的这个矛盾集中在哪个点了，
现在矛盾点集中在对你也是想见一面，
他父母打电话过来了给我，
但是我家人说跟我没有谈好，
你啊，
我来问吧，
也是我的回头客了啊，
第一，
你俩现在是婚姻存续期间的状态是吧？
对，
第二，
孩子是多大了？
孩子现在是在你身边，
5岁多了，
在你这上幼儿园是吧？
对，
第三，
你的爸妈是干啥工作的，
有退休金吗？
毕竟他们是那个做小生意的，
做那个糕点，
证明他们是丢了家庭情况，
是在养父母，
一个亲生父母嘛，
他们俩是亲生姊妹，
你这头有什么工作吗？
现在也暂时先休息一段时间吧，
明年再好，
那你。
现在手上有多少存款，
现在有40个，
这40万的存款主要来自于什么？
自己工作存在的，
因为之前他的工作给我的摊销一般人都很少，
加他的那个彩礼钱，
还有结婚的一些钱，
就不是总共40个，
当时彩礼给了多少钱呀？
8万八说我爸妈给了4万，
你老公他是干什么工作的呢？
他跟编外人员的公务员吧，
他收入大概是个什么状态呢？
大概也就十万以下，
他当时动手打你的时候觉到什么程度了，
严重吗？
打了三巴掌之后，
他说我骂他吧，
她也骂了呀，
他就很暴躁，
那公公婆婆是干什么的呢？
公公也是退休来，
就是8你做退休金吗？
有退休金，
她是那个欠职的婆婆，
没有，
没有公公，
那你现在回到娘家生活了，
你自己感觉咋样？
孩子在这边适应吗？
你在这边在娘家生活开心吗？
第一个星期可能孩子不太适应，
因为可能是在山西生活了一段时间了，
现在适应了是吧，
感觉挺好，
爸爸妈妈包括家里的亲人也都完全接纳你们母子在这里生活吗？
嗯，
是的，
现在养父母这边啊，
你这边父母，
养父母也非常欢迎且接纳你们在这边生活，
是不是？
那养父母这边有没有对你的婚姻发表过什么意见呀？
是同意你离呀，
还是怎么着啊，
他是说。
这男的有点不太好，
不太好，
那你现在想要问我的问题是啥呀？
就是你给我提点意见吧，
我态度上还是有歧实上没有劲儿，
从我自己的角度看啊，
我有了孩子之后，
我感觉我可有奔头了，
我可有劲儿了，
可希望说让我的孩子过点好日子了，
可希望什么好的东西我都能买得起，
都能给他置办得起了，
可有劲儿了，
反正是总得有一个生活的一个牵引，
或者说目标感在前头，
那你现在如果说两口子关系不是很好的话，
如果你自己从原生家庭来说的话，
也没有得到过太多的偏爱的话，
那现在孩子才5岁，
是个小女孩儿是不是？
那我就想想，
我怎么能够挣更多的钱，
我怎么能够成为一个情绪更稳定的妈妈，
我怎么能够成为一个让孩子觉得很骄傲的妈妈，
从这个方向找点儿那个生命的力量感觉。
男女关系这个事儿啊，
尤其是我们结了婚，
生了孩子了之后，
这方面的事儿看得淡一点，
如果说他能够回心转意，
他能够挣钱，
他能够养家，
他能够承担一个父亲的职责，
男女关系这事儿看得淡一点，
就是别指望太多，
我老跟大家讲，
我看那个电视剧是否里面明兰的那个婚姻态度，
就是我现实生活中的婚姻太度，
就两口子相处，
我不能指望他太多，
他只要完成了他的规定性。
的动作就已经很好了，
更多的事情还是得靠我自己，
因为我指望他干这个，
指望他干那个，
指望越多就难免会失望，
生活当中各有各的难处，
失望一多了之后就心生怨怼，
怨怼一多了之后就心生仇恨了，
那这日子就没法往下过了。
如果我是你的话，
假设啊，
还没有到离婚那一步的话，
我现在就是先管好我自己个儿，
如果我现在没有工作的话，
我最起码管好我自己的身体健康吧，
管好我自己的皮肤吧，
管好我自己的这个身材吧，
管好我自己的情绪吧，
每一次见到孩子也好，
见到父母也好，
见到客人也好，
管理自己的情绪。
所有的现在情绪不太好的姐妹，
我真的非常推荐你们到处去听一本书的讲解，
你看这本书你未必看得进去，
因为那本书有点深涩，
但是这本书的讲解有很多人讲过，
很多版本，
很多博主都讲过，
这本书就叫做被讨厌的勇气，
都去读音上去搜，
就搜被讨厌的勇气这本书的解读，
被讨厌的勇气这本书的一个讲解，
你就天天听，
我感觉这本书里面的很多观点注入了我的生命之后，
我的生命质量，
我的幸福指数提高了很多，
它里面有一个最重要的观点，
我今天分享给你好不好，
最重要的观点就是我可以决定我幸不幸福，
我可以决定我快不快乐，
我可以决定我今天的心情和态度。
这个观。
太牛了，
这主宰我可以成为我的情绪的开关，
我可以成为我情绪的邑器，
就这个观点的话，
但放在我的身上的话，
帮我解决了太多问题了，
而现在是这个婚姻，
肯定就是两方家长参与的太多嘛，
无论谁太都是双方的家长参与这个婚姻太多，
先放一放，
先把自己搞好，
先把自己的情绪搞好，
当有一天我已经不再期待别人怎么来对我，
对别人没有那么高的指望的时候，
可能你们两口子还有反转的余地，
最考验的勇气，
感谢你看书的同时的话，
你也可以多听听别人对这本书的讲解，
比如樊登老师，
比如那个陆琪老师，
抖音里面好多博主都讲解过这本书，
你都可以去反复听，
我会反复听人家对这本书的讲解，
去加深里面的那些观点在我生命当中的分量，
记得点赞关注哦。